and you and I will go scatter your
mother's ashes together
so who did you kill is it Amita so ball
doesn't really matter I already know I
just want to hear you say it
[ __ ] you learn this board you didn't
even blink well you do realize that
you're just giving away your country
right it's yours it's always been yours
ki raat is yours i pulled you off the
bus in the first place to pass it on to
you i suppose you take it back you're
halfway there one down one to go
not that I want to put ideas in your
head at least now we know you have a
taste for doing what it takes
well no more putting it off I suppose
well come on and don't forget your
mother
you do realize that urn represents all
that's left of the old archery the pre
corrupt RJ once you spread those ashes
all the tires you have to that previous
life are gone
and then what happens al I suppose you
could do what I did after Mohan killed
Lakshmanan
oh he didn't know that did you
yes your father killed your half-sister
and then your mother killed him in
return I simply continued where she left
off I killed so many people for them but
then I realized I was only using
lakshmana's death as an excuse to do
whatever I wanted it just as you use
those ashes as an excuse to do whatever
you want
god damn
well
who finally made it
you know the one and only time I walked
into this place I came in a sane man and
came out like this
you will come out a king
we'll go on then do what you came here
to do
darling you got to let me know
should I stay or should I go
if you say that you are mine
I'll be till the end of time
should I stay or should I go